yes baby
first of all we throw that word
legendary around a lot these days but
when we're talking about miss Aretha it
is so she is legendary why was she
legendary to you she was my hero she
still is my hero most people say well
you sing so well Patti I said but
everybody needs a hero she's mine I'm
trying to be what she is and I've always
wanted to sing her songs the one I sing
tonight I sing the very end of it at the
end of all of my shows call me the
moment the second so Aretha Franklin is
everything to me and everybody here
tonight
oh honey yes dad don't forget me baby oh
so I hope I did it well
oh no but I love that lady there's
nobody ever gonna be like her nobody
there's a whole new generation of folks
discovering her music now so what is one
song that you tell this generation you
cannot miss when you're discovering
mysteries
ain't no way my favorite song the first
my first saw tonight but I wanted to do
with a cinch and forgot about it I said
I know she's gonna kill it that's one of
my favorite or read the Sun got me
through the worst breakup of my life sat
in a dark room listening to that song
over and over and over had a low sip
with it - sings that high note mmm it's
over
look at you with tears yeah but that's
good do you have a moment with her that
sticks out above India because I know
you all had a many moments we we talked
three months before she passed she
called me we talked about a lot of stuff
and I said to her I already told you
everything that we have to do and do it
Patti I want to do that with you so we
planned it and my singing tonight for
her it makes me feel as though we did
that do it there's a new show on Fox
watching it yes you are
we think the bee is Gladys what do you
think that's what I think do you really
yeah some people thought it was me I
never worked that was the others Gladys
yeah yeah my girl oh my god okay the
queen bee she did made the hair stand up
alone let's see it song yes oh
chandelier oh good yes well it is lovely
to see you
[Music]
[Applause]